ich bin heute hier um meine Stimme für
die Tiere zu erheben deren Stimmen wir
jeden Tag am Schlachthof überhören ihre
Schreie die wir überhören die Familien
die wir trennen die Schicksale die wir
dort verursachen für triviale Gründe wir
stehen als Gesellschaft nicht nur in
Deutschland sondern weltweit vor dem
größten ethischen Notfall und zwar der
Massenvernichtung und Versklavung der
nicht menschlichen Tiere
und der diskriminierungsform des
Speziesismus
Speziesismus bezeichnet die
Unterdrückung und Diskriminierung von
Individuen auf Basis nicht ihre
Hautfarbe wieder Rassismus oder ihrer
Geschlechts wieder Sexismus sondern eben
ihre Spezies die meisten von uns würden
sich als tierliebt bezeichnen wir
streicheln Hunde und Katzen die fühlende
Individuen sind und die wir teilweise
sogar als Familienmitglieder
wertschätzen lernen aber gleichzeitig
schicken wir Schweine Kühe und andere
Tiere jeden Tag in ihr Schicksal am
Schlachthof in diese Unterdrückung in
ihres Sklaverei in den
tierkonzentrationslagern und denken uns
mit dabei und folgender Masse einfach
schweigsam es gibt nur viel Gründe
weswegen sie hier und alle zu sehr noch
nicht vegan sind und dass es Tradition
Geschmack Gewohnheit und Bequemlichkeit
und keiner dieser vier trivialen Gründe
kann die Unterdrückung und Vernichtung
dieser Tiere rechtfertigen nicht vegan
sein ist nicht okay und ich fordere
Personenrechte also Menschenrechte für
die anderen nicht menschlichen Tiere
Horat darf ich darf ich sie direkt am
Anfang was fragen ich bin ja für die
größtmögliche debattenfreiheit in diesem
Land in mir stößt aber bei Ihnen das ist
mir glaube ich noch nie beim Gast
passiert etwas sehr auf Holocaust und
Konzentrationslager finden Sie wirklich
dass man diese Sprache benutzen sollte
und finden Sie nicht dass mein Holocaust
mit nichts und zwar mit rein gar nichts
auf der Welt vergleichen sollte also
erstmal darf man alles vergleichen weil
das ja nur objektive parallelen oder
Unterschiede aufzeichnen keinen
Vergleich an sich nimmt noch nichts weg
von jemanden oder soll irgendetwas
verharmlosen
den direkten Vergleich finden Sie nicht
dass sie damit also aus absolut vor
haben erstmal habe ich jetzt gerade gar
keinen Vergleich gezogen weil holocause
genau Konzentrationslager gibt es jetzt
gerade bei den Uiguren werden wird auch
so genannt das wird auch der Holocaust
dort genannt also Holocaust galt für
viele Unterdrückungsformen und
vernichtungsformen im Laufe der
Geschichte wir verbinden es halt
hierzulande spezifisch okay falsch
verstanden
natürlich Parallelen zum Holocaust des
Zweiten Weltkriegs wo Juden und andere
Minderheiten furchtbar ist behandelt
wurden absolut weggesperrt wurde ich
glaube wir sind uns alle im Tisch einig
wenn wir sagen Juden und andere
Minderheiten wurden damals wie Tiere
behandelt ich glaube da können wir alle
innerlich nicken ich muss ja einmal ganz
klar sagen beide haben definitiv keine
gleiche Meinung zum Holocaust und ich
würde diese Vergleich auch niemals
machen Frau Kelle in der Runde weil ich
finde quasi abseits dem verbalen
vergleichen irgendwie finde ich es
schwierig sozusagen wenn man
unterschiedliches gleichsetzt also nicht
umsonst irgendwie gibt es keine
Menschenrechte für Tiere weil viele
Tiere sind und das andere sind Menschen
und nun können Sie sagen ich finde es
falsch irgendwie dass man dass man
Lebewesen in Spezien einteilt haben sie
gestörtes Verhältnis zu Fakten eben
werden aber das hat sich ja niemand
ausgedacht sondern das ist
unterschiedlicher im übrigen auch
unterschiedliche tierspezien gibt ist
nun erst ist nun etwas was sozusagen
fakt ist gleichzeitig finde ich sollte
man auch anerkennen dass es ja
erstens mal nicht nur irgendwie um um um
Willkür und Gewalt gibt einfach nur weil
wir Freude daran haben sondern dass es
das ist ein Nahrungsmittel ist das ist
ich halte es für völlig legitim Fleisch
zu essen warum auch nicht da ist das
legitim wenn Menschen warum ist warum
sollte ich relevante sind Menschen ja
das andere
sind weiße Menschen das eine sind Frauen
das andere sind Männer deswegen haben
Frauen
wo ist der ethisch relevante Unterschied
die DNA die paar Moleküle die uns
ausmachen nein wir sind gleiche Maße
fühlende Individuen ob ich jetzt eine
Katze trete macht sie miau und hat Angst
wenn ich eine Kuh trete macht sie Mut
hat Angst sie dürfen wenn ich ein Mensch
eine Katze gar nicht treten weil wenn
nämlich in diesem Land tierschutzrechte
haben ja aber natürlich ist mir das
bekannt vielen Dank ich bin seit zwei
Jahren tierrechtsaktivistin das ist mir
bekannt aber warum dürfen wir Katzen
nicht ermorden und abschlachten Menschen
nicht ermorden und abschlachten aber
Kühe Schweine Küken und Schafe schon wo
ist da der relevante Unterschied genauso
wenig wie die Hautfarbe beim Rassismus
eine Rolle spielen kann darf das
Geschlecht beim Sexismus auch keine
Rolle spielen wenn ich also Objekt
verwende warum die Spezies wenn ich
jetzt einen dna-wandel habe durch einen
Regen laufen der verändert meine DNA und
wir wachsen Kuh Ohren und ich gehöre
Spezies mäßig nicht mehr zu homosapien
sapiens sondern bin jetzt homo kuniens
und kein Mensch mehr dürfen Sie mich
dann zum Schlachthof schicken ich hoffe
doch nicht weil ich immer noch ein
fühlen dass Individuum bin weil sie
anerkennen und ich glaube das ist ihre
Position als Liberaler Mensch ja auch
dass wir alle ein Recht auf körperliche
Selbstbestimmung haben warum sollte das
an der Spezies Grenze enden wenn wir
erkannt haben dass die Hautfarbe auch
keinen relevanten Faktor hier darstellen
kann ja weil das ist doch jetzt also
genau also da muss man schon das ein
oder andere auseinanderhalten da kann
man ja schon drüber also so Holocaust
Vergleiche oder Relativierung und solche
Geschichten geht gar nicht vor allem der
Unterschied ist ja die Singularität
dessen ist ja dass man Menschen und ich
glaube schon es gibt auch noch ein
Unterschied zwischen Menschen und Tieren
dass man Menschen maschinell umgebracht
hat also man hat ja genau darüber können
wir gleich sprechen man hat in jegliche
würde dadurch genommen dass man sie
einfach maschinell getötet hat und das
ist finde ich das ist persönlich etwas
dass es Singular und das sollten wir
gerade als deutsche auch sehr
verantwortungsvoll behandeln das andere
was man hätte diskutieren kann ist
Tierschutz Tierrechte was ist der
unterschied davon die stehen für Tiere
Rechte ein äh ich also ich werde jetzt
nicht sagen ich hatte heute Mittag ein
Schweinebraten in der Kantine ich hoffe
ich bin für sie jetzt kein Mörder
wahrscheinlich mein Vater ist Landwirt
gewesen ich bin auf dem Bauernhof
aufgewachsen deswegen hatte ich auch
viel Berührung mit Tieren und da waren
auch Schweine und Kühe und so weiter und
das aber eigentlich ein relativ oder ein
rechtschaffender normaler Mensch der
einfach seine Arbeit gemacht hat und ich
finde man sollte schon den ein oder
anderen Respekt davor haben wenn
Menschen ihre Arbeit machen und damit
umgehen das man muss es ja auch wenn man
es politisch betrachtet ein bisschen die
Perspektive weiten und sagen wir haben
in Deutschland ziemlich hohe Tierschutz
Standards die weltweit sage ich mal
ziemlich einzigartig sind und wenn wir
jetzt hier anfangen politisch betrachtet
das alles denn den Rest an
Landwirtschaft den wir noch haben ins
Ausland zu verlagern dann ist weder für
Tierschutz noch für Tierrechte
irgendetwas gewonnen und deswegen man
muss ja auch gucken man kann die ein
oder andere Position haben man kann da
radikaler sein oder weniger radikaler
sein man muss doch am Ende darüber
sprechen was kann man konkret erreichen
und man erreicht konkret nichts wenn man
in Deutschland dafür sorgt dass hier
Tierhaltung reduziert wird
auf dem Bauernhof aufgewachsen sind und
Frau Raab sie haben gesagt wer Tiere
essen will muss auch Tiere töten können
das glaube ich nie gesagt und nur weil
ich es kann ist dass keine
Rechtfertigung nur weil ich jemanden
vergewaltigen
zitiert das heißt sie sagen nicht essen
kann muss auch tun nein also töten kann
ist das ja keine Rechtfertigung es zu
tun das macht es ja für das Opfer nicht
besser das ist ja deswegen nicht den
also auch gegen die Jagd beispielsweise
natürlich ich darf ja auch nicht den
Wald gehen und dort Urvölker von
Menschen abknaben aber was machen wir
denn jetzt zum Beispiel also dass das
Tiere das Lebewesen sich gegenseitig
fressen ist ja nun sozusagen nicht nur
etwas was Menschen
Tiere ja auch untereinander was machen
Sie denn mit den ganzen
fleischfressenden
Menschen anfangen
Politiker erwartet komplett meiner Frage
ausgeglichen wo ist der ethisch
signifikant der Unterschied zwischen
einem menschlichen Tier und einem nicht
menschlichen Tier und dass sie heute ein
Mensch wir sind Tiere wenn ich eins von
meiner Medizinstudium gelernt habe ist
dass sie ungefähr den gleichen Aufbau
haben wie das Tier dass sie heute
miteinander
Unterschied ja aber wo ist der relevante
ist gar kein Hund dass ich dass ich
Schweine
bekannte Unterschied dass ich Tiere
essen darf kommen wir nun mal zu einem
Unterschied Menschen sie sagen ja was
zwischen Menschen und Tieren der
Unterschied ist eine Sache an sie mal
ganz kurz wir beiden würden uns ja oder
hier am Tisch jetzt nicht gegenseitig
reißen oder essen oder angreifen in der
freien Wildbahn leben die Tiere aber
nicht wie wir Menschen zusammen setzen
sich an den Tisch und debattieren und
geben sich dann die Hand sondern in der
freien Wildbahn weswegen ist ja die
nachhaltige Jagd auch gibt
der Natur schützen möchte dann könnte
ich Menschen abknallenge
Politikerin
meine Frage immer noch nicht beantworten
ich habe gesagt wir Menschen essen uns
gegeneinander
Essen und reißen sich aber Tiere gegen
seine
relevanten Unterschied ich kann Ihnen
trotzdem eine Antwort auf dieses
Argument bieten was sie machen sondern
naturalistischer Fehlschluss nur weil
etwas in der Natur so passiert darf das
keine Rechtfertigung für uns sein als
auch an den Tieren ja also wir dürfen
unsere Moral nicht nach etwas in der
Natur wenn jetzt ihr Punkt war was wir
machen sollten wegen Tieren die sich
gegenseitig angreifen ich sage Ihnen ich
würde eingreifen wenn ich gerade sehe
wie ein Raubtier ein ein Beutetier
angreift genauso wie ich sie auf auf dem
Löwen auch beschützen möchte aber bevor
ich in die in die Wüste gehen kann und
dort dafür sorgen kann dass jedes dieser
Raubtiere mit pflanzlichen Fleisch
Ersatz ernährt wird und solche Ansätze
gibt es durchaus schon dieses Thema in
der veganen tierrechts Ethik nennt sich
wild animal suffering und es ist einfach
füttern ja nein nicht darf nein zunächst
einmal würde ich natürlich mit Menschen
sprechen die jeden Tag die Entscheidung
dreimal am Tag treffen können ob sie
jetzt dann Individuum in einen Massaker
reinschicken und ihr ganzes Leben lang
versklaven lassen oder ob sie sich Obst
Gemüse Getreide Sojabohnen Nüsse
Bohnensamen und Vitamin B12 einfach hast
du Supplement nehmen ohne dass du so
eine
gewisse wird jetzt ein bisschen
grundsätzlich aber ich glaube schon es
gibt einen grundsätzlichen Unterschied
zwischen was ist ein Mensch und was ist
ein Tier und das und das liegt daran
dass wir Menschen ein freien Willen
haben dass wir eine emotionale
Intelligenz haben
das gibt uns eine verfassungsrechtlich
begründete würde die Menschenwürde und
die unterscheidet uns grundsätzlich von
allen anderen Lebewesen die wir
zumindest kennt die unterscheidet uns
übrigens auch von Maschinen ist gerade
bei KI interessant also zwischen
Maschinen und Tieren steht der Mensch
und der hat eine ganz bestimmte eine
eigene Würde der hat ein freien Willen
eine emotionale Intelligenz und das
bedeutet schon im Grundsatz ja wir
müssen Tiere schützen aber Tiere sind
eben keine Individuen und sie haben
keine eigenen und sie haben keine
eigenen Rechte Tiere ja also rechtlich
werden Tiere wie Sachen behandeln das
ist nicht meine Überzeugung ne also
Tiere genau das war falsch
ich finde nicht dass ihre Sachen sind
aber Tiere sind keine Individuen Tiere
sind zu schützen und deswegen müssen wir
beitragen dafür arbeiten wir politisch
aber Tiere haben eben keine
individuellen Rechte und es gibt ein
graduell nicht nur ein graduell ein
qualitativen Unterschied zwischen Mensch
und Tiere
rechtfertigen kann
Emotion meine Persönlichkeit welches
Kuscheltier am liebsten mag wohin am
liebsten spielen geht was für den Bezug
dazu Menschen ich glaube die meisten
Menschen in unserer Runde die schon mal
einen Hund oder eine Katze gestreichelt
haben würden dem Mädchen aber Schweine
sind die fünf intelligentesten Tiere der
Welt sogar intelligenter als Hunde die
haben eine größere emotionale Kapazität
als Hunde und dennoch haben
es ist falsch zwischen Hunden und
Schwein zu unterscheiden und da sieht
also all diese Tiere haben wir in der
Runde ein konkreten Schritt weiter wir
haben eine Aktivistin hier ich kann ihr
Anliegen verstehen ich bin selbst
Vegetarierer
sind sehr klein oder was glauben
die Politik hier
Maximalforderung stellen kann ich
kommunikativ verstehen aber was ist der
nächste Schritt sie kriegen ja die
Maximalforderung nicht sofort umgesetzt
wobei äh
Tierschutzgesetzen bei ökologischen
Standard wo wo kann man den nächsten
Schritt machen meinetwegen auch
international damit man nicht immer auf
die anderen Kalender zeigt als
Rechtfertigung also die individuelle
Anforderungen an diese Runde hier und an
alle zu sehr ist keine
maximalanforderung sondern eine
Minimalanforderung und zwar einfach
keine Gewalt mehr an Tieren auszuüben
ich glaube jeder einzelne von uns stünde
da jetzt eine Kuh der gerade für Sie als
Vegetariern weil Vegetarier dass das
Kalb weggenommen wird sie als Mutter
müssen das doch verstehen ja schön dass
Sie das da so abgebrüht sind dass sie da
keine Emotionen mehr dazu haben ich
glaube die meisten von uns würden
einschreiten wenn wir wenn wir dieser
Kuh ihr kalbchen wegnehmen müssen für
ein bisschen Milch im Kaffee für ein
Stückchen Käse für ein Stück von ihrem
Beinen das ist in dem Moment sie hat von
Menschlichkeit gesprochen ja wir sind
dann der Spitze technologisch gesehen
sind wir stärker als alle anderen aber
es gibt uns eine Verantwortung
menschlichkeit ist Verantwortung wir
fragen jetzt einmal bei Frau Keller nach
weil sie haben mir sehr emotional
gezeigt woran es ihm liegt Frau Kelle
wurden sie jetzt überzeugt von den
Maximalforderungen heute Abend
nur noch von Luft und Liebe und Gemüse
essen Leben ich finde es nicht
überzeugend weil es und ich fürchte sie
werden auch niemanden überzeugen weil
wir grundsätzlich zwei Positionen
gegenüberstehen haben nämlich dass sie
ständig vermischen
Dinge die nichts miteinander zu tun
haben dass sie Dinge vergleichen die
nichts miteinander zu tun haben dann ist
das ihr gutes Recht aber man kann damit
überhaupt nicht weiter weil wir sagen
wenn wir uns nicht darauf einigen können
dass Tiere andere Lebewesen sind als
Menschen können dass wir einen
unterschiedlichen Rechtsstatus haben
dann haben wir ja nicht einmal den
ersten Schritt von dem an wir weiter
denken können und zweitens wenn ich der
Meinung dass sie nicht das Recht haben
irgendwie der Menschheit vorzuschreiben
wie sie ihre Nahrungskette gestaltet
weil eben Fleisch essen jetzt nicht nur
etwas ist wo man sagt ja ist jetzt
irgendwie individuelle Entscheidung
sondern es ist etwas was eine
ausgewogene Ernährung ausmacht und was
eine Mangel
ja es ist einfach
so absolut das ist so totalitär so nach
dem Motto es gibt entweder man ist vegan
oder man ist ein Mörder ich mein
Entschuldigung ja das ist doch
lächerlich irgendwie aber ich hätte noch
eine Frage weil weil mich etwas
irritiert hatte ich hatte gesehen sie
setzen sich für Frauenrechte ein unter
anderem sind sie für Abtreibung nein ich
bin für
bewusstseinheit dafür sie sollte also
für das Recht einer Frau ihr ungeborenes
Kind töten wenn es nicht aber sie sind
dagegen eine Kuh wenn das Kind nichts
fühlt wenn es kein bewusstes Individuum
ist und wir haben immer noch nicht
abonnieren im Mutterleib nichts fühlten
Woche haben wir keinen
wissenschaftlichen Industrie
ehrlich
sind Frauen zu retten und für sexuelle
Freiheit dann sollten Sie aufhören für
Milch und Käse kühl vergewaltigen zu
lassen
geschnitten werden Babys die in ihrem
Leid ersticken die ganz bestimmt fühlen
können im Gegensatz zu den zehn
eishalte fest als Ergebnis für sie ist
es in Ordnung wenn Frauen ungeborene
Kinder töten aber in Ordnung
sehr richtig die nichts fühlen können
mit dieser Einigkeit nicht Einigkeit
sondern in der These also Frau Keller
liegt eine ganz kurze Unterbrechung
trotzdem danke an Frau Raab dass sie
sich hier der Debatte stellt und wir
wollen ja alle Meinungen hören und nach
der Werbung sind wir zurück wurden sie
abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall